Lisa nandi is here good morning it's
always good to see you thanks for
joining us on the program so much to
talk about I wonder if we could start
with Sue Ella bravaman sure what do you
think
the Prime Minister should do well I
think he should just tell her to answer
some basic questions about what she
asked her civil servants to do I think
most people looking at this are thinking
why is the government now involved in
this ongoing saga about what happened
with Zoella Braverman and some speeding
course that she did or didn't do there
seems to be a lot of tension between her
and the Prime Minister I think there are
big issues that the Home Secretary is
failing to get to groups with
um the backlog in the Asylum system the
fact that a lot of people now don't feel
safe to walk the streets not just at
night but in broad daylight I think
these are the things that the homes
actually should be focusing on and I
think if she came out and just answered
some basic questions about whether she
did or didn't break the ministerial code
we would be in a better place as a
country I wonder if she did well I mean
I don't think people should break the
ministerial code to be completely Frank
I'm not going to start speculating about
whether she should resign or not I don't
know what she's done the problem is none
of us really exactly know what she's
doing the code or not I mean it's like
being a bit pregnant you either break
the code or you don't well I I think
sometimes there are you know there are
people who who break the code or blur
the lines in the code inadvertently and
there are people who egregiously breach
the code you know we saw it during the
pandemic where you had a prime minister
who broke the rules uh having made the
rules he lied about it and he laughed
about it that is appalling it brings
politics into disrepute it lets people
down it lets the public down it's not
good enough the problem in this case is
that the Home Secretary is just in
hiding again she's failing to answer
basic questions about what she did or
didn't do and meanwhile the Asylum
system is in complete chaos you've got
these crackers plans to start housing a
consignancy because on barges and
sending them to Rwanda it's costing us
huge amounts of money we've got real
problems with crime in every part of the
country you've just been covering uh you
know disturbances we need a home
secretary who's going to get a grip on
this and a government that can stick
together work together and sort these
problems out speaking of blurring the
lines that's exactly what Rachel Reeves
did she blur the image of the fact that
she was sat in a posh seat going to
Washington what's that about well I I
don't know I mean if you want social
media advice you're asking the wrong
person but she's in she's in New York at
the moment making the case for more
investment in Britain as the person
who's going to be tasked with leading us
out of this
seriously I've never been to 3K so I
don't know but I mean ask her what it
was like I certainly will I mean you
know it but it's I don't really care as
you're sitting on the plane what I care
about is whether when we inherit the
worst economic situation since the
second world war whether we can attract
the investment to get good jobs back
into constituencies like criticize the
government for flying around in Posh
seats when you do exactly the same thing
well look the reason that people like me
got pretty annoyed with Rishi sunak for
flying to the north of England is
because I'm fairly clear that he did
that because the trains are in such a
state of chaos and for those of us who
try to travel not just on those National
lines but particularly the regional
lines which have been a disaster not
just for the last few months but for
years and years it's annoying when you
have a prime minister who's flying
around in private jets because he's not
fixed the problems that the rest of us
have to deal with what would you do what
number would you have for net migration
if you were in power well we we expect
net migration to come down and we want
to see it come down but there are two
factors well there are two factors that
have pushed it up relatively recently
obviously Hong Kong and it was right I
think that we opened up to people bno
passport holders coming from Hong Kong
given what is happening there
particularly with the actions of China
and also Ukraine and I think most people
would accept that it was right to say
that we would welcome people to come
here from Ukraine but there's a third
reason why there's a real problem with
net migration and that is because for a
long time the government has
consistently failed to invest in the
skills of our own Workforce we've got
not just young people who can't get good
jobs in this country but we've got a lot
of over 50s who would like to return to
work but there is no Glide path
currently for them to do it they lose
their benefits the training and support
isn't there and so they can't get back
into the workplace we'll change that
with Jonathan Ashworth our shadow work
and pension secretary has got a plan to
invest in the health of the nation in
order to help people back into work and
to fill those labor shortages we
shouldn't just rely on trying to attract
people to come here from overseas we
should be investing in our own people
should foreign students be allowed to
bring all their rallies with them
um I think I think we need to be I think
we need to have some flexibility in the
rules to allow for individual
circumstances but I don't think that we
should just create new routes for
migration when we have a points-based
system that currently isn't working but
should do is write in principle you know
the point of the points-based system
which the last Labor government
introduced modeled on what happens in
Australia is that where you've got gaps
in the labor market that you can't fill
with people here in the UK that it's a
good thing to then open up and attract
people to come to this country okay that
should never be an excuse for not
investing in people okay I'm all ears on
the um on the story that you want to
talk about today uh Banning lease
holding
um tell me more will you do in the first
hundred days so we'll we'll introduce
legislation in the first hundred days it
takes some time for it to go through the
Parliamentary process as you know it
goes from The Commons to the Lords and
back again and and it's right that
legislation is scrutinized but we'll do
it without delay and the reason that we
will is because there are five million
people in this country who are currently
struggling with this feudal archaic
system England and Wales are outliers in
the world in having held on to this
system where you save up you get a
deposit you get a mortgage you buy your
own home only to find that you don't
actually own it you can be hit with
arbitrary unfair charges you can't
challenge them you don't know where
they've come from nobody is under any
pressure to explain even why they're
charging you that money I know welcome
to my world well there's so many people
well aware of it it is horrendous for
some people it's just an irritation it's
something that is unfair but for a lot
of people this is literally ruining
their lives Michael Gove knows it myself
people can buy a section of the Freehold
yeah so what what what we've said is
exactly what the secretary of state was
proposing in January the law commission
did a report three years ago end uh
leasehold for new builds end lease holds
on homes and for where you've got Flats
where you've got lots of people who need
to hold the lease in common you
introduce a form of common hold so they
can take over the lease of their own
building together works in Australia
works in the United States works all
over the world no reason why it
shouldn't work here
um Dominic Rob won't be working after
the next election I suspect he might he
might get a job not in the House of
Commons no you won't be working in the
house Commons that is true somebody's
going to stand down at the next election
sorry about that um well I shattered him
for quite some time we always had a good
working relationship there were moments
obviously the withdrawals from
Afghanistan you know we we had very
strong disagreements about we had
disagreements over China but we always
managed to work constructively together
I think he probably wouldn't have wanted
to stand down in these circumstances but
you know I wish him well for the future
I think politics is a very brutal
business especially when you're at the
top of politics and you've held some of
the briefs that he has he said in the
statement that he's got young kids and
he wants to put them first I think most
of us who are in politics could probably
understand that okay it's always great
to see you thank you thanks indeed
thanks a lot